were to don't want to get the copyright
I'm Greg
John Pat subscribe click that
notification dogs recovering Super Bowl
spots we actually didn't cover this one
yet and it's the first one that came out
top gun maverick let's check this
trailer out only 30 seconds long hey
it's Top Gun baby
[Music]
[Music]
Oh little nugget of sand inside him just
reading over that is very effective it
would to space I don't think this any
any of that eighties Camp cheese flare a
zombie a tone poem with no actual plot
no dialogue disguises the whole
passional narration this looks great man
it's like true intensity and I get the
impression actually that you've talked
about topic on maverick a few times
already but I don't think you need to
watch the first Top Gun 2 to appreciate
this film I'm just getting that vibe
that even if you haven't seen the first
Top Gun that you can walk into this one
and I'm sure they'll recap whatever the
hell you need to read yeah but it just
seems like such a different kind of film
and so much more intense and I don't
know what the reception was in the 80s
if it was just you know consider like a
really fun exciting film I don't know if
the word intense was thrown around for
that flick this is like the main Flair
I'm getting from all these trailers is
just pure adrenalin intensity it looks
kind of scary you know I feel like an
IMAX this will be a really scary movie
to watch yeah Tom Cruise is really up
there flying yeah and for some reason
when you know this isn't like a person
who's been training all their life to be
a pilot it somehow gets more scary yeah
but yeah I mean they're leading with
that and the gravitas is just what I get
it's like you know maverick he's an
elder statesman and yet he just can't be
pinned down you won't stop that verdict
I just hope that emotional intensity the
drama is not cheesy like like
unintentionally cheesy that's just my
one concern but it's very slight because
I just totally but it's like mine this
is a Tom Cruise movie and like you don't
need to go in with a Baxter even if
you've seen the 80s you get the idea of
like okay he was a really cool guy when
he was younger now he's an older cool
guy but there are more guys that
trying to be cool yeah he's now going to
do all the things that Tom Cruise does
which is fly cool planes go to space
exploration of his coolness and if it
was anyone else we wouldn't have this
gripping of like are they gonna die
because you know Tom Cruise got in a
fighter jet yeah I went up to the
Earth's atmosphere and risked his life
so that we can pay $10 to say cool movie
and Tom Cruise would never let himself
die in a franchise no not unless that
was like an amazing shot ya know if it's
for the audience he's willing to commit
I mean if you just that's like Tom
Cruise the gay like the maverick
character he would know who just won't
let it happen down there's no passing of
the baton here even though you got these
younger players like miles teller could
do any time travel is like you're gonna
die just like your dad just go go away
not last I was real bad goose the
character I don't know is real bad can
we get a fact check on miles tellers
really okay if he is not then this is
really another one we've been camp
otherwise all right guys well Top Gun
maverick what a great way to kick it
like out of any trailer to kick off the
Super Bowl this is the Super Bowl this
is yeah I mean it's like guys subscribe
click bells keep a lookout for what the
next one is that we're gonna be covering
so you guys